a 9 and 13 pitcher and a 310 era
sandy alcantara and look at all those
innings
yeah a ton of innings right there again
four pitch mix with that high velocity
fastball for him at 97 and 99 we talked
about and that change up that he uses
extremely effectively so pirate here is
going to have to be ready to hit
and going the other way
is key brian hayes
kevin newman
bunts jackson pounces throws to first
and they get the out sacrifice goes 2-3
told all too often
throughout sandy's career but we are now
ground ball to second
and ben gamel is retired hayes moves to
third but there are two away
swung out and missed and a strikeout for
alcatra works around the lead-off single
and strands that runner at third against
max kranik
a scranton pa kid 11th round pick of the
pirates back in 2016 out of
valley view high school which uh by my
understanding less than 25 miles away
from dunder mifflin this will be his
seventh major league start
pop up
kevin newman
and there's
strikeout number one for crannock
i believe so
struck him out boy good looking
first inning
for max kranick
a little tapper oh misplayed
and safe at first
here we go again
tucker on the move
throw down not gonna get him
cole tucker
steals second and now 3-2 count on
alford
changed to an error on the right fielder
and a little dribbler
oh look at this it looked like it hit
alfred and tucker doesn't slow down and
the pirates score
again the hustle plays i mean speed the
kills you know you have two guys on the
base pass that can run a little bit
hustle beats balls out again anthony
alpha comes out of the box hot
puts pressure on the defense so when
that happens good things can happen
and just take advantage of and end up
scoring our first run
not playing clean baseball from that
marlins defense again don mattingly is
going to claim that uh alford was not
running in the lane this comes up a lot
but uh
it's not
going to be
reviewed with the umpiring crew yeah
that
indianapolis
another strikeout form that's three in a
row
well
max
is off to quite a start here that's four
straight punch outs
yeah nice job right there
wow
oh my
mad max
five consecutive strikeouts
shades of st louis
runner goes swinging to miss jackson's
throw is in time
jazz with the pick and the tag to get
newman short hop throw and tag
sure did got him on the left shoulder
sandy off of first with two outs
jazz that's true for a base hit
tucker fields it and here comes the
throw and gets all the way to third but
sandy is there standing first and third
for the marlins
[Applause]
reaching out and a fly ball toward right
center and tucker is there
o'cranic escapes
and that's lace toward right center
field how about cole tucker all the way
to the wall
jacob stallings gonna be held at third
is cole tucker having himself a series
in miami
payoff pitch
and a chopper to third alvarez has it
comes home and
throws perfect and what a tag by alex
jackson they get stallings at the plate
well the defense had been a little
sketchy early in this ball game but
maybe the defense is starting to wake up
what a play by eddie alvarez on the run
and by alex jackson at home there was no
margin for error
chuck and duck jazz knocks it down and
steps on the bag pirate strand a couple
and now it's joe panic
three for his last 28 but a chance here
with sanchez at second and diaz at first
two and two
panic line drive face it right center
field sanchez coming around third he's
going to score leon diaz getting the
green light here he comes through from
park to home is high
and joe panic gives the marlins the lead
in the fourth
[Applause]
that's right back through the box a hot
shot in the center field and jazz is
headed toward third he'll get there
this one in the left alford is there
jazz will tag
and head home
a sac fly for jesus sanchez
marlon's
and another hit for cole tucker
what a series
and that's a fair ball inside the third
base bag and of course cole tucker can
run
alford can fly he's rounding second he's
headed to third and he is there with a
trip trip triple it's a triple and an
rbi for alfred and the pirates within a
run three to two here in the seventh on
hayes and one away
ground ball bender's got it throws to
the bag jazz comes down with it throws
to first and that's a double play
a huge double play for bender in the
marlins to protect a one-run lead
newman is the runner at second plenty of
speed to score
ground ball
legwin's got it
flips to blyer who gets to the bag
great play by lewin diaz most
importantly protects
a one-run marlins lead
walked him
in business in the ninth
one out in the pirates ninth hoy park
will bat
arc drives on to deep right
this one's deep had gone boy park has
put the pirates in the lead in the ninth
inning
a go-ahead two-run home run
and the pirates are up four to three
he takes ball four
jazz ground ball
park's got it the flip and they gotta
throw goes to third and sierra moves up
[Applause]
and he will a base at center field
sierra scores and the marlins have tied
it in the ninth
brian de la cruz right up the middle
4-4
fastball 92-94 miles per hour
that'll work right there yeah little
wild pitch action
and now gamma lines one toward right
field catch made sacrifice fly gives the
bucks the lead
camel was not going to be denied this
time after striking out
on three pitches in the eighth inning
with lewin diaz to lead things off
leewan
fly ball
right field tucker back
[Music]
[Applause]
you